bonjour madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonjour monsieur vont jouer l'hymne
guimond jour un italien ces messieurs
ont diamantis seniors seniors
voilà vous avez tout compris nous sommes
en italie
et oui alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire en
italie 1-1
la pizza a fait ça mais attention hein
la pizza italienne elle est trop bonne
alors moi j'ai pas su leur faire alors
j'ai fait ma pizza à moi un avec ma
patte à moi regarder ma pâte à pizza
les italiens nous n'arrivons plus jamais
faire que celle là après 2e que je casse
dans ce cas un petit saladier déjà à amy
l'as rome les cheveux se dressent les
enfants ça fait rien ça fait rien il
faut causer dans la vie je bats mais eux
en omelette
voilà ici devant moi 300 g de farine que
je mets dans un grand saladier
notez bien les quantités les enfants car
on n'a pas le temps de vous faire des
panneaux au milieu de ses 300 g de
farine
je me fais un petit puis comment dire le
type et l'italien je mets dans ce petit
regret piccolo chritopher pincée de
sucre en poudre
voilà j'ajoute une pincée de sel et la
caisse que j'ai devant moi des la mesure
du boulanger 15 g de levure du boulanger
que je pose au milieu de ce piccolo
pitau j ajoute un tiers c'est-à-dire 710
litres de lait tiède je dis bien tiens
voilà et avec un doigt bien propre où je
le précise je commence à faire fondre ma
levure du boulanger car en fait si elle
son départ eh bien on aurait les côtés
de pat qui gonflerait tu sais ça serait
le vésuve
alors là c'est la recette ft et pisé est
là
là une fois que j'ai mélangé ma le jure
dans mon lait tiède ça y est tu vas me
verser mon poulet doucement doucement
voile en asie vas-y d'un coup voilà de
mai 2e qui sont battus légèrement est là
qu est ce qui me reste à faire à
mélanger doucement tout ça pour obtenir
une pâte qui doit être une pâte qui
tiennent qui tiennent légèrement un peu
mollassonne pas trop alors là tu vois
par exemple elle est presque elle est
parfaite je n'ai pas besoin d'y ajouter
de farine si par hasard
ainsi par hasard elle est un peu trop
liquide un peu trop molle n'hésitez pas
les enfants ajoutez y un peu de farine
mais là tu vois
elle est absolument parfaite alors là
qu'est ce que je fais je prends un autre
saladier tuque a enlevé celui-là dans ce
saladier je mets un tout petit peu de
farine
je pose ma patte dessus j'ai ici quoi un
linge torchon je pose mon torchon dessus
et je mets au chaud c'est à dire dans un
endroit tiède de l'appartement pour une
heure et demie voilà alors je vais être
obligée d'aller me laver le même outil
pendant ce temps là tu vas chercher la
pâte va chercher la pâte je t'attends
celle qui est au chaud depuis une heure
et demi au dessus du four voilà pose là
là on va soulever regarde les deux
torchon voilà celle que je viens de m oh
là là et voilà ce que c'est devenu et ça
je vous le jure c'est la même bon alors
j'enlève met hors champ là je suis
obligé vu mon état il allait me laver
les mains tu sais ce que tu fais tu me
farine la table celle qui me sarine la
table tu prends de la farine non non non
là bas là bas l'abba ici la voilà
me fallut de la table pour que je puisse
y étaler la pâte a largement oui ça lui
ben écoute je crois moi je suis jeune
voilà tu me dis ah ça c'est bien je suis
sûr que ces forums je suis patient
[Rires]
excuser la seigneurie c'est la rega la
regarde alors regarde on peut enlever
celles la chaîne
alors là j'ai devant moi un grand moule
avec le fond amovible qui va c'est un
moule qui fait 32 cm alors qu'est ce que
je fais je il a exceptionnellement avec
et l'huile d'olive
moi je suis pas un fana mais pour une
fois il faut sacrifier au folklore savez
ce que c'est alors je suis largement
et puis je vais éteindre ma patte
alors là c'est pas difficile d'étendre
la pâte le plus difficile de ce qu'il
faut l'étendre en chantant alors c'est
toi qui vas chanter tu as une très belle
voix alors regarde là tu vois cette pâte
qui fall est allé à la main c'est à dire
qu' il faut que je la pousse
petit à petit comme ça de façon à ce
qu'elle arrive à la taille du moule
alors tu vois comme ça c'est un bien en
asie
au sommet on peut pas le faire ça ça ça
s'étale pas vas-y vas-y compter les
quantités système et regarder alors vous
faites bien attention bien sûr parce que
vous ne fassiez pas de trous dans la
pâte
elle est belle hein comment tu vas
trouve à manger tout ce travail
là je pense je vais baie comeau dessus
une seconde je suis presque encore un
petit coup ici là tu vois là comme ça
alors là la pizza la vraie pizza ils né
forment pas dans des moules comme ça
elle tient tout seul moi je sais pas
alors je prends ma patte
hop je la pose comme ça dans mon la
caisse qui me reste à faire enlever ce
cas de trop ici est tout simplement
retourner légèrement partout où il le
faut bhl abords de la tente
voilà et cette pâte on va la laisser
lever une deuxième fois
pendant que nous préparons quoi les
trois ingrédients
bon alors les trois ingrédients de la
pizza d'abord la tomato la tomate vous
le savez pour faire une pizza filmé par
une vraie pizza italienne mais qui est
la nôtre dit tomates s'est dit tomates
il faut l'épauler
alors pour peler les tomates le système
la trempe dans l'eau bouillante salée ce
même 10 10 secondes c'est ça alors on
compte jusqu'à 10 finissent encore 10 9
8 6 5 4 3 2 1 0 c'était un type non je
déconne et la tomate tu peux enlever le
petit bol merci et puis cette tomate
j'enlève le pédoncule lp donc cully un
italien qui l'a mis au pluriel moi
j'aurais dit que d'un culot et là je
trouve que ça fait grossir la commission
qui prend du genou les enfants je crus
les mutins pas le feu très bien je break
smalto matt entre mes doigts et ça c'est
pour enlever les pépins ma dixième
tomates ne change pas de conversation
mais je resterai tomates je vous ferai
remarquer que le cycle automates sont
hélas pas mûres il fait exprès et
maintenant me 9,6 verve et le dixième
tard et enfin ça fait rien bon et là
devant moi j'ai une casserole
ici comme ça que je vais laisser
chauffer et là devant moi j'ai une poêle
que je pose sur un feu et dans cette
poêle exceptionnellement et pour vous
faire plaisir
je vais mettre un peu d'huile d'arachide
car je vais y faire cuire des oignons et
les oignons avec me délivre plus c'est
pas le pied l'acier un bon tu peux
l'enlever la bouteille à s'en servir
dans cette poêle g si beau oignons que
j'ai coupé en tranches fines jeu les
ajoute dans la poêle voilà je les salles
légèrement jeu les poivrons prix je
salue légèrement car on va mettre des
anchois
on va mettre des olives noires et tout
ça ça quand même tendance
et là tu vois tu fais sauter un peu
comme ça et puis il faut que ces oignons
confits il leur faudra 15 minutes
ici dans ma cocotte je mets trois
cuillères à soupe d'huile d'olive
ils allaient cela et j'y ajoute tout de
suite la chaire de may be tomates comme
ceci près qu'il en joue comme d'habitude
tout de suite un peu de sucre en poudre
car enfin la tomate adore aussi
confondre un peu de sel comme ceux ci
pas trop toujours un peu de poivre
comme ceci
on peut regretter en poudre je prends
une peau cela le bel je commence à les
langes et une cuillère en bois est
devant moi qu'est-ce que j'ai deux
grammes d'ail haché fin ces deux-là
nouveau les enfants en ce moment il est
extraordinaire mais deux grains die
nouveau hachée fin est là qu est ce que
j'ai encore la basilique près alors le
basilic créé avec leïla thomas alors je
prends mon basilique
et puis aux ciseaux qu'est-ce que ça
sent bon le basilic c'est incroyable
c'est tout l'été un c'est toute la
provence
c'est vrai c'est l'italie c'est les
vacances c'est fantastique et je me
lâche comme ça une quinzaine de feuilles
de basilic largement tout bois sans
avoir peur dans les tomates
voilà alors là ça on va doucement le
laisser cuire 1 ici encore un tour de
poil ça va trop vite fruits et ça va
trop vite alors je baisse mon feu à les
épinards les épinards voyez va garder
d'avoir moins ce que j'ai j'ai 5 à 600 g
d'épinards qui sont lavés et cru j'ai
également de l'huile d'olive donc très
peu une cuillère à soupe d'huile d'olive
au fond de ma grande cocotte
j'y ajoute mes épinards encore deux
grains die à ses fins je n'ai pas du
tout je sale comme ceci
et qu'est ce que je fais je remue et
puise à le voir immédiatement
en quelques secondes on va dire les
épinards vont réguler et ils seront
assez cuit à ce moment là pour être
mieux dans la pizza car en fait c'est
pas la peine de trop les tirs si vous
voulez bien regarder vesela bourassa
vous le montrez les trois couleurs
qu'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
les enfants le drapeau italien pour un
jour de 14 juillet il faut le faire hein
alors alors là ça y est j'y suis
regardes tu vois s'est réduit qu'est-ce
que je fais là tu vois ce suprême
je prends mes épinards ici tu me passes
un autre torchon jeu les verts sz
comme ceci pour les faire refroidir dans
une petite passoire et puis maintenant
je vais pratiquement plus m'occuper de
ça pendant 15 minutes c'est à dire de
temps en temps un petit coup ici pour
les remuer et ici laissez réduire pour
que ça fasse une superbe pâte et on se
retrouve dans 15 minutes pour finir la
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà quinze minutes sont passées mes
tomates sont prêtes par contre evelyne
tu l'as vu j'ai atteint mes oignons au
bout de dix minutes alors dans les
oignons j'ajoute quoi et 4 breaks 2
cuillères à café à peu près de quatre
ans je mélange et je pose mes oignons
ici comme ceci mais thomas tu as he will
ne faut pas le jeu de la tomate
sinon la pizza ça serait plus une pizza
ça serais je pas mal un lac incroyable
plein de rouge et tout alors tu vois
jean lève un peu mon jus et voilà comme
ça si tu vois pour n'avoir plus que ma
chère de tomates qui sont bons l'ail
nouveau et le basilic
alors là c'est maintenant les enfants
que nous allons faire la cocarde
tricolore italienne c'est à dire rouge
blanche verte alors extérieurs vont
semer la tomate
tu sais les italiens ils font de
superbes pizza mais il aurait tendance à
mettre leurs couleurs les unes à côté
des autres en tranches alors moi je me
suis toujours demandé comment on pouvait
arriver à goûter les 3 alors je vous
signale amis italiens qu'ils nous
écoutent et que j'ai fait breveter mon
procès n'essayez pas de le prendre
voilà première couche extérieure bien
mes tomates et maintenant on va attaquer
les oignons
deuxième partie de notre drapeau
les oignons se chevaucher un peu hein ce
sera meilleur
les oignons comme ceux ci qui sont plus
très loin tu vas te retrouves devant les
blanchit on va les blanchir au nord on a
un truc un fromage italien qui délicieux
qui s'appelle l'amour de mohammadia et
la mozzarella voilà merci qui ne sert
strictement qu'à faire des pizzas tiens
tu parles de ça d
milieu avec des livres avons à bord et
là on est mieux
je mets mes épinards le pas mis beaucoup
un joli et là qu'est ce que je vais
faire la mozzarella voilà des anchois
les voilà des olives les voilà alors si
si on se mettait des petits filets
d'anchois comme ceux ci en décoration
tout autour ça serait pas mal
qu'est-ce que tu en irait tout ça je
vous le répète amis italiens
c'est pas une pizza italienne mais vous
nous connaissez nous français cette
vision formellement est totalement
chauvin on veut bien un peu mais pas
trop
ensuite pour blanchir regardez-moi ça as
tu la prends pas une et c'est long je
suis là nos oignons la mozzarella bien
rangés comme ceux ci sur les oignons
c'est koné et entière la la ça c'est
quand elle est entière oui à couper un
train je les couper en tranches
exactement et là maintenant si on se
mettait pour faire joli ah oui je sais
je sais nous sommes comme ça des petites
olives noires comme ceci alors
maintenant il va nous rester tout
simplement à mettre un petit filet
d'huile d'olive
sur les tomates et sur les épices et
pinard déjeuner ou four thermostat
maximum c'est à dire 10 pour 12 minutes
300° 12 minutes au four
jbe allez c'est parti
y a plus qu'à prier ensemble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et voilà douze minutes après alors là si
vous pouviez sentir
alors regardez cette pizza il faut
l'enlever de sur le truc elle regarde ce
que j'ai deux sous sl est déjà là dit je
pose à alexandrie belle à regarder ça je
vais te couper une belle part je me sers
beaucoup de clientes ils iront jusqu'au
bout les regarde moi je te coupe
qu'est ce qu'elle est belle qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle on va faire des
envieux ddans même amical ici tu vas
vite et ça moi je vois pas en quoi et
vas-y vas-y vas-y
[Musique]
c'est bon